hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's time to talk
about
nen nen useful nin that is in the world
of hunter hunter
and we're doing this because when it
comes to nano i suppose more accurately
hatsu
and inabilities there is a lot of focus
on power who has the most powerful hatsu
to wield and then combat but fighting
really is only one aspect of life a
pretty big aspect i will admit
in any given shonen series but it leaves
so many fantastic abilities completely
underexplored so here we are today to
recognize not the most powerful
but the most useful abilities that would
completely revolutionize life as we know
it which you know as nice as the 100
type guanine bodhisattva is it has
fairly limited applications for your
day-to-day person especially if you
haven't trained in the mountains for
like a decade
and also before we begin this video is
sponsored by the anime collective who
make all sorts of fun anime related
clothing to proudly display in public
they have an incredible range of not
only hunt hunt based merch but also a
whole ton of other series including one
piece naruto jojo and most likely
whatever you want there's a link in the
description below with a 10
discount code which is great because
worldwide shipping is also available
and they have sizes up to 5xl along with
plenty of reviews and testimonials to
peruse so instead of just sitting there
likely naked as per usual
go and clad yourself in some of this
fine streetwear but for now let's get
into some incredibly useful nun
abilities starting with number 10
perfect plan kicking us off we have one
of my favorite chimera ants meliaron and
his absolutely insane ability to turn
invisible in fact
actually goes quite a bit beyond that as
a chameleon-esque ant-man meleoron
actually came equipped with the natural
ability to access invisibility prior to
the advent of nin within the colony and
once melion was rather brutally
initiated into the world of nen
perfect plan was developed which makes
melierong completely undetectable by
almost any measure which includes sight
obviously but also
hearing touch or any kind of extra
sensory ability this includes
n by the way which means that even the
greatest of nen users would not be able
to counter your effective removal from
existence
the downsides are this ability can only
be performed for as long as the user can
hold their breath and actually there is
one form of detection which is via smell
so it's not quite a perfect plan but
it's pretty damn close
and this sort of advanced invisibility
would be pretty ridiculously useful
as we have seen in the series but it
would also have a limitless number of
real world applications as well
certainly an ability i would have my eye
on
as well as number nine 14 devils heading
to the realm of greed island now it's
very hard to deny anything razer related
to spot on most lists but 14 devils is
probably his more underrated ability
because razer is best known as the
poster boy of a mission throwing orables
and investing his aura into the emissive
mechanics of greed island
however the fact that he can just create
eight nine beast servants to do his
bidding at any given time is also
amazingly useful i mean just imagine if
you could do something similar it would
make any task requiring labor much
easier because you function as your own
crew and you could even order them to do
more menial tasks like clean the house
because you know if they can play
dodgeball then they can use a vacuum
and if you do find yourself in a
situation where you need a bit of a
power boost well these nine beasts can
combine together to form
stronger beings capable of assisting you
in most of life scenarios it's just
highly overlooked because all we've
really seen razer use them for is some
good old dodgeball and because razer
himself is such an imposing figure
but don't underestimate the 14 devils i
don't think a single person would be
complaining with access to this ability
and hopefully they wouldn't be
complaining with number eight
machi's threads because it really
doesn't matter what series or power
system we're talking about
someone with the ability to generate and
manipulate strings is always going to be
supremely overpowered
and machi is no exception in fact in the
case of machi's threads hers are a step
above most as they are seemingly
completely unable to be severed or cut
in any way
while provided they're used properly as
their durability is said to equate to a
one meter strand being capable of
lifting one
ton of weight so already i suppose the
threads are useful for moving things but
in addition to that they can also be
used in the classical puppeteering way
to take control of people
or they can even be used as a mechanism
of healing in fact especially healing
because via transmutation machi's
strings possess some sort of innate
rejuvenation qualities but you can also
do things like tracking the movement of
targets by attaching a super long strand
to them
because it is implied that the length of
these strings are essentially limitless
with machi claiming that she could
create one as long as the earth's
diameter
although it would be rather weak as a
result like cotton so very easily
severed but in conclusion
strings are good but do you know what
else is good poetry
and that is exactly what we have here in
number seven with great haiku
so there are times in this series where
i really think togashi doesn't quite
realize what he's created and great
haiku is one of those instances
this ability allegedly has the power to
create quite
literally anything all you need to do is
write it on a piece of paper
and bam it becomes real the problem is
you do need to write it in the form of a
haiku and as a secondary problem you
can't even phone it in either the haiku
needs to be well written
because if it's a bad poem then the
generated ability will be significantly
weakened
and that's quite problematic for bosher
because he is he's not the greatest of
poets
but the heart to itself is still
astounding and even in the hands of a
poor writer it is completely
life-changing you might have to work
that little bit harder but i'll say it
again
whatever you write becomes real it's one
of those abilities that has
quite literally limitless applications
it is restricted only by the creativity
of the user
both in terms of language mastery and
desires to bring things into reality
were it not for those factors great
haiku would be an easy easy easy number
one
but because it is slightly difficult to
wield it will have to settle for number
seven and as for number six we now have
parallel future
so this one might be new for those of
you who have not read the manga but it
is a pretty cool power held by the
the terrifying fourth prince saratnik
and if you're a jojo fan this ability is
actually very easy to explain i have two
words for you
king crimson there are differences
between the two in parallel future as a
more underpowered version but they are
strikingly similar to the point where
togashi almost certainly just
took the idea and decided to explain it
using his own rules
but in very basic terms when saradnik
enters a state of zetsu he is then able
to receive a vision of 10 seconds into
the future this vision occurs instantly
with no time having passed in reality
however if he exceeds that 10 seconds
and time in reality begins moving
forward with zaradnik perpetually
looking 10 seconds into the future hence
the name parallel future and it's on
this list because even if it's only 10
seconds any brand of future site is
generally pretty amazing there
are situations where it could save your
life or even situations where it could
save you mild embarrassment in public
there is no situation where i will ever
argue with being able to see into the
future which leads us
quite nicely into number five lovely
ghost writer
and now we are taking future sight to a
whole new level except in the interest
of balance we do of course have far more
restrictions but the great advantage of
this ability is that it can predict a
person's future roughly a month in
advance however it does so via poetry
another shockingly powerful poetry based
hatsu so here's the thing
after having lovely ghost writer used on
you you will see a road map of your next
month or so but it will be up to you to
interpret the meaning of the metaphoric
language which if you are successful can
be extraordinarily beneficial but it can
also be quite tricky and even the sharp
minds of the phantom troupe were unable
to completely understand their own
fortunes
until the events themselves were well
into motion another problem is that the
user of lovely ghost writer can't
predict their own future so that does
kind of suck but this power would make
you an indispensable asset to the world
you would become a very rich person very
quickly much like neon's father and as i
said before i will never complain with
any ability to see into the future
but let's get well away from this topic
now with number four and it is going to
be
rider's high one of the most frankly
ridiculous looking abilities in hunter
hunter and yet one of the most useful
because it fulfills the very basic
basic need of transport this allows the
bonnet to transform into a variety of
vehicles two of which we've seen
are a motorcycle and a glider pretty
amazing yeah
there is one problem though being that
this power cannot be used without a
rider because the vehicles themselves
use the aura of the rider as fuel so it
does require some
combination maneuvers but it is still
pretty damn incredible and this is
something that i talk a lot about in one
piece videos on my other channel
but never underestimate the basic power
of flight
especially when we're talking about
utility no riders high is not the most
powerful ability by any stretch of the
imagination
but it is certainly one of the most
useful although perhaps not quite as
useful as number three
glitch will be bungee gum because being
able to command the properties of both
rubber and gum
still remains one of the most versatile
powers that we have ever encountered in
the series and whilst hisoka mainly uses
it for combat it has a pretty wide range
of basic applications
even if you are the most lazy
non-combative couch pheasant you could
use bungee gum to just grab
things and bring them to you rather than
get up and if you were a more active
bungy gum user then this is an easy
solution to spy demanding your way
around
city and if you are ever in any kind of
trouble then bungee gum also acts as an
ultimate candy based unbreakable shield
it's another one of those hatsu that
really is only limited by imagination
and i quite frankly do not possess the
mind to pursue bungie gum to its
pinnacle but i do recognize the
potential that exists within it still
something that intrigues me more is
number two hide and seek because from
the moment nov first demonstrated this
ability
i knew it would be one of my favorite
things that this series would have to
offer the power to essentially create a
pocket dimension which you can slip
easily in and out of at your convenience
is one of the most appealing thoughts i
could ever have plus the potential for
storage transportation and almost
effective
teleportation is just unbelievable
especially because it doesn't seem to
come with many conditions or
restrictions
which is very rare for such a powerful
ability like this and it really would
speak to novel's almost certainly
astounding raw or
output it is undeniably useful but not
quite what i would call
the most useful before we get into that
though i do want to address something
that will
inevitably come up in the comments which
is skill hunter
this ability is not going to be featured
on this list many people will probably
try to make the argument that the
ability to take other abilities
is both the most powerful and most
useful by default and they would be
right
if it were not for just how difficult
skill hunter is to activate
satisfying the slew of conditions
required to take an ability with skill
hunter almost certainly makes it
entirely useless to anybody who isn't a
mastermind of crowler level it just
cannot be used by an everyday person and
to the extent that it maybe could
it would not be able to capture anything
but abilities from very very low level
and inexperienced end users which why do
we even want those
it's just too difficult to make work and
that's why we're not even coming close
to considering it but with that said
let's move on to our ultimate
number one which will be magical spa
services
and just stay with me here biski is an
insane character
most often remembered for her potent
power and body transformation hatsu but
very few people dwell on magical spa
services which amongst other things has
been said to relieve fatigue burn excess
fat or even
cure arthritis all via being able to
create a lovely masseuse named cookie
and some specially transmuted lotion
although one of the craziest benefits is
a specific massage known as the piano
massage which will make 30 minutes of
sleep the equivalent of eight hours
and with that alone this ability would
basically allow you to live twice as
much life as anyone else
because you'd really only need half an
hour of sleep every now and then
but of course it does have the other
aforementioned longevity effects as well
making this far
and away the most useful hearts win the
series in my opinion i honestly actually
don't think that any of the others even
come close
they're all nice for basic pieces of fun
utility but magical spa services will
ensure that you live a long
infinitely productive and profoundly
relaxed life and there is nothing
more useful than that but what do you
guys think please do leave your thoughts
in the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
some more hunt hunter content then
please do go and check out some of my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel
for regular hunter hunter glory
delivered straight into your youtube
feed
but for now this has been the new world
review and i'll see you next time